watch dogs and Assassin's Creed of both
open-world action games designed by
Ubisoft Montreal and like a bunch of
recent Ubisoft games they share pretty
similar structure you know the one climb
a tower to open up activities on the map
or take out an enemy outpost to gain
control over an area that sort of thing
but what makes watchdogs different
what's going on to appeal to people who
are burnt out on Assassin's Creed well
here are four ways watchdogs might win
over Assassin's Creed haters get five
Assassin's Creed fans in a room and
chances are you'll have five people who
couldn't care less about the modern
animus sections of the game or as we
refer to them in the office the [ __ ]
parts oh sure you'll find the occasional
person who can kinda sorta tolerate
Desmond Miles but you'd be hard pressed
to find anyone who really loves the way
every Assassin's Creed game includes
jewel storylines watchdogs doesn't have
any of that stuff to weigh it down this
is a story as aiden pious and his own
problems in modern-day Chicago for
better or worse what you see is what you
get who knows whether the story will be
any better than Assassin's Creed and it
will certainly be told in a more direct
way well that's a bunch of you who are
fans of the rooftop parkour way of
getting around any given Assassin's
Creed game there's also a sec do you
think it's a fairly tedious way to
explore an area not to mention the way
you run down is straight and then
accidentally end up sticking on the edge
of a building running around on foot can
be fun but also pretty time consuming in
the long term and for those people
there's just one thing to say cars yes
watchdogs employees all the magic of
modern automotive technology just hop in
a car legally illegally we weren't judge
and explore the city of Chicago at
breakneck speeds in that regard
watchdogs feels a lot more like Grand
Theft Auto that Assassin's Creed but
unlike those early GTA games so driving
in watch dogs is actually pretty fun
Assassin's Creed has always been pretty
heavy on the swordplay and Malik combat
but watch dogs is a whole other beast
entirely you can play it like a third
person shooter if you want but you can
also craft gadgets like sticky lures to
sneak by God's unseen or set off car
alarms and steam pipe explosions to
create even more of a ruckus and if
everything goes to hell and you need to
pull the nuclear option just trigger a
citywide blackout and sneak away under
the cover of darkness it's a game with a
lot more ways to approach combat than
Assassin's Creed although unfortunately
that means there are no brutal aerial
takedowns can't win them all Assassin's
Creed has always had its fair share of
comic relief characters but on the whole
series is tended to be fairly serious on
the surface watchdogs looks like it's
going to be following a similar path but
dig a little deeper and you'll find a
game that knows how to have a little fun
when it wants to the most obvious
example our digital trips which are
those eccentric mini games you can play
in a bizarre alternate version of
Chicago you know like piloting a spider
tank as it crawls up skyscrapers and
destroys everything in sight that kind
of stuff everything you've been hearing
about cyborgs and watched on yeah this
is that Olaf watch dogs will still
probably be tinged with that Ubisoft
formula but I think it's gonna have
enough surprises to keep those of you
who answer keen on Assassin's Creed
interested let me know whether you think
this one is overhyped or whether you're
excited for it last week I talked to you
guys that Wolfenstein the new order and
here's what you thought about it the
more lies added health does regenerate
but I guess we didn't play the game
you're right that it regenerates but
only a very small portion of the overall
health bar so those med gets a skill
super important while some of you still
think the game qualifies as mindless see
Reaper 210 said I'm loving the game I
got like 10 hours into it and I'm
halfway through the game so it's pretty
beefy for a non open-world FPS and scalp
aneesa's watered it noted it you forgot
to mention that you can eat dog food to
recover health yep that's a very
important point that's it for me be sure
to leave your thoughts in that
commenting section and I will see you
next week
you